wants to quantify things we are number
and then of course everyone is constant
through this number so I wanna ask
captain up here and I'm gonna give a
number related to carry and it's a
measure of relevance so the number
that's Kevin is 88 billion and I would
let all right I wasn't going to explain
that to you but I know you could ask me
at the coffee break or something that's
a number that sort of trying to find my
slide changer and failing we could just
not change the slides that's surprising
all right well
this was part of it oh you know it's in
there somewhere
okay here we go yes so that's a number
that has to do with the FCC incentive
auction the upcoming spectrum options
their ongoing spectrum options of
telling a massive oh--this at a coffee
break and this is a sort of intermediate
amount of money that the u.s. government
has procured the right to buy a bunch of
spectrum for which is unlikely to end up
being the amount of money that they
actually have to pay but I'll tell you
that story as we get to that part of the
talk after the break but there's a
little teaser okay so I'm gonna talk to
you about trying to understand the
empirical hardness of np-complete
problems I guess I'll begin by trying to
give you some sense of what I might mean
by those kind of strange terms let me at
the outset just mentioned that this talk
is going to be surveying a whole lot of
different papers over a period of about
15 years particularly with these
collaborators here holger who is another
professor at UBC and is a close
collaborator of mine Frank hunter who's
a former PhD student and postdoc now a
professor in Germany Eugene Nudelman who
was a fellow PhD student at Stanford saw
the error of his ways and went to Google
you'll show em who's my adviser at
Stanford Saudi Airways went to Google
went to Stanford went to Google to
Stanford now it's in Israel and Lynn
true who's a former PhD student and I'll
just sort of throw out block citations
at the beginnings of sections and not
really call attention to individual
papers but of course everything is a
collaboration and at the outset let me
point out that this talk is really going
to be a bit different from the others
that you've seen in the bootcamp you can
guess which one of these I am so so the
empty seats are either reflect other
people not you who knew this and wisely
stayed away or people who are still
eating we'll find out as time goes on
but the way that this is going to be
really different is that this talk is
not really going to have theorems in it
and I don't think the your a theorem
statement even appears anywhere yeah
exactly
let me give just a moment for people who
might realize they left something in
their office to duck out instead it's
it's really gonna have a bunch of grass
even worse I'm really going to be
thinking about kind of empirical ways of
thinking about the kinds of questions
that I think people here are very
interested in and think about
theoretically at the beginning of this
talk I'm going to try to persuade you
that nevertheless you should care about
this after which we can have a 30-second
break and see what happens because much
of this is going to be methodologically
pretty different from what I imagine
many of you are used to let me
especially stress to you that I welcome
your interruptions and questions
throughout the talk think it'll be more
fun for all of us if you guys just feel
free to jump in as indeed some of you
already have felt free good for you but
but yeah please jump in and let me
mention that you're as strange as this
all is look at us here right here in the
description of the the workshop I was
looking at yesterday like wow
there's actually make sense so what I'm
really going to be talking about
particularly the first half of the talk
is alternatives to worst-case analysis
of algorithms using ideas from machine
learning couldn't have said it better
myself so so that's what we're going to
begin by thinking about so going to an
algorithms textbook you know it's
something that gets thrown around a lot
as people say np-complete problems are
intractable so so I tried to go look at
an algorithms textbook and get a crisp
definition of what people actually mean
by intractable and did this was sort of
the punchiest definition that I can find
problems are intractable when they can
be solved but not fast enough for the
solution to be usable well strictly
speaking it's not really right to say
that this is the case of np-complete
problems because the reality is is a lot
more complicated about that of course
that's that's true in the worst case
unless you know deep theoretical results
get proven that make all of us very
happy and make somebody a million
dollars but the state of the art today
is that there exist methods for solving
and p-complete problems which offer
typically no interesting theoretical
guarantees at all but they were
ridiculously well in practice probably
much better than many of you might be
aware and they typically exhibit kind of
exponentially varying performance by
which I mean very often they're very
very fast even on enormous enormous
instances you know milliseconds or
seconds to run on really big instances
where you know often the the solving
time is dominated by reading in this
enormous instance but then occasionally
on problems from the same distribution
and of the same size they take really
long amounts of time and then everything
in between as well so you know much of
the time in practice we can just kind of
ignore worst case complexity theory and
just proceed onwards anyway and do
really well but then once in a while
things are really terrible and so a
question that I've been really animated
by in my own work is trying to
understand how hard is it to solve a
given problem in practice using the best
available methods and this is a question
that you would sort of hope as a
practitioner to turn to complexity
theory to get an answer to and if what
you're interested in is np-complete
problems you'd be pretty disappointed by
the kinds of advice that complexity
theory can give you about the solving
problems in practice using the best
available methods it's not to say that
complexity theory has absolutely nothing
to say but it has very little to say
about the really complex algorithms that
we use in practice that exhibit good
performance and I guess I I hope to
learn at this semester from some of you
about the cutting stated the art of what
what is known about complexity theory
but I think it's still pretty safe to
say that there's there's a pretty giant
gap between what's known and what we're
able to do in practice so here's kind of
the main message of this talk even in
settings which are sort of as bad as you
could imagine things getting from a
formal analysis point of view where
algorithms are complex black boxes you
know I might think about something like
SEAPLEX which is you know an
astoundingly fast commercial solver for
mixed integer programming and it's not
just that it's really really hard to
analyze because it's so enormous ly
complex but in fact it's a trade secret
they don't even tell you how it works
you know if you go at a conference and
you talk to the people who work for
cplex they sort of snicker and they tell
you they won't tell you how their
algorithm works so you really don't know
how this thing works and and when you
have an instance distribution which is
somehow richly structured it's not a
uniform distribution over something but
it's some you know actual distribution
that arises in a practical application
area of interest even in settings like
this it's possible to to say something
meaningful about how algorithms perform
in a kind of generalizable way that we
can learn something from and and the key
idea here is to use rigorous statistical
methods rather than kind of
combinatorial or analytic methods that
probably are closer to the hearts of
most of the people here I I suspect that
this kind of math is probably less
exciting to many people here less less
in your wheelhouse
here's even if that's true why I think
you should care about this because even
if you think as I guess I would agree
that this kind of you know analytic
worst case proving a theorem kind of
approach is is more satisfying it's more
bulletproof the success of statistical
methods it demonstrates the existence of
patterns that we don't yet understand
and so you can really use these
statistical methods to find regularities
in the ways that algorithms behave and
and then these are really actionable you
know robust generalizable claims that I
think can be a great starting point for
theoretical analysis so you can kind of
think of many of the methods that I'm
going to be speaking about particularly
in the first half of the talk today as
kind of open problem generators that you
can use to to think about what might be
going on in a family of problems and
then maybe that can give you a starting
point for synth Arian and just to sort
of whet your appetite there's one point
in the talk where I'll I'll dive deep
into how one of the the findings that we
have works just to give you a sense of
what the sort of open problem generator
approach might look like so this is not
a talk about sat
this is really a talk about the methods
that we use sort of statistically to
reason about sort of beyond worst case
complexity of hard problems particularly
on P complete problems
nevertheless I'm gonna speak most but
not quite all the time about
satisfiability because empirically it's
a really widely studied problem so this
is a place where the instance
distributions have been thought about
very carefully a wide range of
high-performance solvers that are
different from each other have over a
long period of time being kind of
evolved by the community so this is sort
of the fruit fly of empirical
algorithmics this is just the sort of
testbed that everybody comes to to to
make sure that some idea that they have
really holds up and so for that reason
it's sort of the most responsible thing
for me to look at sad for for the kinds
of things that I want to say to you but
but as I start going on and on about sad
I hope that at the coffee break you
don't say oh that guy was giving a talk
about Sat because really very little
that I say is is gonna be really
particular to the domain but of course
because it's empirical I'm gonna be
speaking about a domain so I want to
begin by talking about this phenomenon
the probably many of you have heard
about of phase transitions and
satisfiability and despite my claims to
the contrary this is a point where I'm
gonna be speaking about a uniform random
distribution of instances you'll notice
in my sort of outline thing at the top
here I'm going to begin for a while
speaking about uniform random 3sat and
then I'll go beyond that to other
distributions INSAT before probably
after the break speaking about
applications and the reason I care about
uniform random 3sat is not because I
claimed that it's a practical really in
any way it's actually pretty artificial
but rather because we understand maybe
some of the best here about what happens
on average and then how that correlates
with the performance of strong solvers
and it's a problem that people have
really studied to death so if it's
possible to say something new here
though there's really a chance that that
one is really saying something new so
let me tell you about this phase
transition so you guys have probably
heard about this fact that there's a
phase transition in the probability of
solve ability at a clauses 2 variables
ratio of about four point two six so so
let me show you this with a graph that's
based on real data so here I'm showing
you we generated a bunch of sat problems
I think these were with 500 variables
and the appropriate number of clauses
and so then we varied the the ratio of
clauses to
labels in in generating these various
different problems and we looked at what
fraction of those problems were
satisfiable and so this is a size that
we can solve all of them using modern
Sat solver this is getting close to what
we can't solve but but this we can solve
and you see what happens is when the
clauses 2 variables ratio is pretty low
which means you have relatively few
clauses to the number of variables
clauses amount to constraints so you
have relatively many variables
relatively few constraints then the
chances that you can find a satisfying
assignment for this problem are
basically 1 and this is because the
problem is under constraint there are
lots and lots of solutions there are
lots of ways that you can solve the
problem so intuitively you would expect
that up here the answer would be 1 and
for the same kind of so opposite reason
you would expect over here that it would
be 0 because when we get enough clauses
then your problem is over constrained
there are lots of reasons why your
problem can't be satisfied even if you
were to drop a few clauses you still
wouldn't be able to satisfy it you know
all the solutions are ruled out by sort
of multiple closets and so so kind of
intuition would tell you that you know
you should have a region of ones here
and you should have a region of zeros
here what's interesting though is that
the transition from the region of ones
to the region of zeros comes really
sharply it comes as a phase transition
and in fact this transition gets sharper
and sharper as you have more and more
variables so you know I'm showing you no
empirical results for a sort of moderate
number of variables so you can still see
a bit of a slope here but as it gets
bigger bigger we know theoretically gets
sharper and sharper so so far this is
not anything to do with algorithms for
solving sad this is just a property of
uniform random generation of sad
instances
here's though something about heuristic
algorithms so this is a graph of the
long runtime of a relatively strong at
the time we generated the graph one of
the stronger solvers for solving uniform
random 3sat problems and what's
interesting is that it goes from being
very easy this is log run time so really
really easy to quite hard to easier as
as we come to this phase transition
point and in particular there's a spike
in hardness right at this nice
transition point it's really
across different solvers that the
hardest uniform random 3sat problems are
those ones that live at exactly the
phase transition they did not prove
3.2.40 like people say 4.3 but that's
because they're rounding off I think
that really is I think there's some kind
of formula for it and people have over
time sort of I mean I think it's three
point two four well I think there's a
whole literature on this that I've sort
of periodically looked at actually can't
claim to be expert on it but there there
are known kind of upper bounds and lower
bounds I'm on what this transition is
and you you might be giving a lower
bound yeah
but but then I think there's there's
some other approach that tries to
estimate where the actual threshold is
and I think the best current estimate is
something like four point two six but
but it's possible that's only where it's
coming from but but anyway I think it's
not hard to see in the data it's not
three point four you know really it
isn't that's possible let's let's talk
about this afterwards because I really
won't play a role in what I want to say
going forward what I want to say just is
notice here that we've related something
about the instance to something about
the empirical performance not of kind of
clean algorithms that we can understand
really really deeply but of messy
state-of-the-art algorithms that perform
as well as any algorithms that we can
find I think this is sort of that the
cleanest and and maybe the earliest
example I know of a relationship between
some kind of general set of hard
problems and sort of every good
algorithm that's known out there rather
than some toy algorithm that sort of is
a tool for analysis and this responder I
think I an enthusiasm for using
empirical methods to study this kind of
algorithm performance now so so this was
was real data about KC NFS let me show
you the actual data that was underneath
this real data that I showed you so so
it turns out this
here well you know what does this line
actually represent it represents the
mean at every one of these points so let
me not show you the mean let me show you
the actual underlying data and this is
the underlying data and this is a graph
that probably many fewer theorists have
seen before and this shows that that
story that I told you before is much
messier than you might have thought
because there's an awful you know pick
any kind of vertical slice here this is
the amount of run time variation that
you have at any point as you vary the
closet availables ratio and you know
I've put here a dotted line at the phase
transition region which is the hard
region and you can see that here at the
phase transition region we have problems
that are taking well under a tenth of a
second and we have other problems that
are taking sort of as much time as
anything does and you know overall
there's there's a bigger clump of these
problems up here so the mean is is large
but you know isn't that kind of
surprising by the way you might see
other graphs like this so let me mention
to you why is there this banding here
that's just the resolution of the CPU
timer because it's on a log scale it
blows out these small numbers yeah so
that that's a you shouldn't be worried
that something fishy is going on here so
so this shows that there's more going on
that is as much as this causes the
variables ratio had something
interesting to tell us about a
structural property of the instance in
the performance of kind of
state-of-the-art solvers we're certainly
not explaining all of the variance you
know closeted variables ratio doesn't
give me a way of knowing whether I've
got this instance or whether I've got
this instance and I might wonder is
there something different about these
two instances that causes them to have
different performance well one thing
that I can condition on that that is
already pretty interesting is the
satisfiability status of the incidence
which is not something of course that I
get to know before I run my solver but
it's nevertheless a structural property
of the instance and here is the
distribution conditioned only
unsatisfiability status so you see that
this big kind of fuzzy regime is the
satisfiable instances which is you know
and in contrast these are the
unsatisfiable instances which are much
more kind of homogeneously grouped
together and and that might not be
surprising if you think about the fact
that there's something fun
different in practice about proving
satisfiability improving
unsatisfiability you know in this under
constraint region there are many
satisfying assignments typically and as
soon as I find any one of them I get to
stop and so I expect to see high
variance run times in the satisfiable
regime because I don't know it's
something very particular about the
algorithm which of these things I'm
gonna find first in the unsatisfiable
case I have to have to prove something
about the whole formula and regardless
of which order I go through I can maybe
prune parts of my search space but I
still have to kind of reason about the
whole search space so I end up with much
lower variation yeah really the the run
of the solver sort of amounts to approve
it doesn't return it cuz it can be
exponential size but it it does sort of
certify that there's no solution do you
have any intuition as to why it slopes
downward for the non satisfiable
instances why does it get easier these
ones get easier yeah I do have an
intuition about that and I guess that's
that's the kind of question I want to be
thinking about throughout this talk so
so great to be thinking about it now
kind of intuitively they I think the
intuition is that the search space gets
smaller because you sort of you keep
throwing random constraints and sort of
think of I mean it's sort of a bad
analogy but you can sort of
geometrically think of like random
hyperplanes and a MIT problem or
something I mean it you keep throwing
them in they're gonna bite more and more
you can have a smaller and smaller area
to be searching and and furthermore that
area's gonna be kind of more and more
regular it's gonna be easier to reason
about and so as you get more and more
constraints you have to do sort of less
searching to demonstrate that there's no
solution that satisfies any of your
constraints and so the intuition is that
right here at the phase transition with
the probability of satisfiability is 50%
if there's a solution there's probably
only one solution and if there's not a
solution then probably you know dropping
one constraint would have allowed you to
have a solution like you almost have a
solution and so that's the place where
it's hardest to sort of demonstrate
whichever thing it is and you know here
it's just it's much easier to
demonstrate it but you still have to
search the whole space which is why you
never kind of get down to this
sticks for solving the Saturday yes so
does this graph look same across the
security yes broadly speaking we see the
same kind of pattern among you're not
looking at complete solvers for said
that can prove on Sat of course there
are local search solvers that can't
prevent that and then we wouldn't we
wouldn't have the second group of points
because we couldn't prove on Sat but
yeah broadly speaking among complete
solvers we see this pattern and you have
to take my word for it I'm only showing
it to you here for KC NFS but but really
this is what has made empirical research
is really excited about this problem
because as different as the different
algorithms are we end up still with this
kind of pattern pretty robustly anybody
else before I go on so then the kind of
state of things we are where we stand as
we begin our story today is that we know
that the probability of solvability you
know correlates really strongly with
instance hardness and practice but when
we dig a little deeper and look at the
scatter plot we can see that there's a
lot of residual variance there's other
stuff going on and we don't really know
what that is and you know the question
that animated our work is to ask is it
possible to be more accurate than this
is it possible to somehow you figure out
what's driving some of that other
variance and you know I guess there's
there's sort of multiple approaches one
could take if one were you know really
smart mathematically minded person then
one might try to think about what's
going on and prove a theorem that might
sound appealing to you but it sounds far
too difficult to me so instead what
seemed appealing to me would was to
gather a whole lot of data and throw a
machine learning algorithm at it and see
if it could figure something out and so
this is something you know we did back
when I was in grad school just sort of
as a Hail Mary to see if something came
of it and and we sort of stubbed our toe
on something really interesting because
it turns out this works a lot better
than than I and I think a lot of people
I've talked to over the years thought
that it should have and I guess this
talk is about sort of digging into the
implications of that so so this is
something we call empirical hardness
models and I'm going to begin by talking
about these models in the context of
this uniform random 3sat problem that
I've been motivating with and then as I
said before we'll scope out after that
so what we want to do with what I'm
calling an empirical hardness model is
to predict
how long an algorithm will take to run
on some distribution of problems of
interest and as is typical in machine
learning the way I want to think about
this distribution is I want to take a
bunch of iid samples from the
distribution and for each of these
problem instances each of these samples
from the distribution I'm gonna measure
some vector of feature values and I'll
have a little bit more to say about what
these feature values are but essentially
I want these to be things that are cheap
to measure about the instance I don't
want them to sort of correspond to
solving the instance or I'd be begging
the questions I want to ask something
sort of computationally non demanding
about the instance and then furthermore
for all of these samples that I'm gonna
get to build my model from I'm gonna
have a labelled observation which is the
runtime of whichever algorithm it is
that I want to characterize running on
that problem and now I've just got a
supervised machine learning problem I've
got a regression problem and so I'd like
to find some mapping that can be given a
new instance from the distribution that
I've never seen before I can compute its
it's inexpensive features and then I can
evaluate this learn mapping and it'll
give me a run time without my ever
running the algorithm it'll give me some
prediction of how long my algorithm
would take to run on this new problem
and then I could compare that by
actually running the algorithm and that
problem and see whether my my learning
algorithm works well or not and if so
then I've found this model this kind of
analytic F that that can be evaluated
without running my algorithm and that's
going to sort of incorporate some sort
of understanding some sort of theory
about what drives the performance of my
algorithm and and we can we can do all
the things that we know about from
machine learning to make sure that this
thing is robust that it's making real
predictions to gain some kind of
statistical confidence that that we're
not just kind of coming up with garbage
here in the papers that we've written on
this we've spent a lot of time
evaluating a variety of different
machine learning methods and you know
various differences of tweaks on the
methodology should we log transform the
response variable how do we deal with
censored observations there are a lot of
subtle things that I'm not going to get
into although I'd be happy to discuss
them with those of you
this choice makes a difference and I
guess at the end when I get to this next
section here I'm gonna give you a sense
of what our very best methods are doing
and how they contrast with simple
methods but I think the first order
message that I want to convey to you is
that this works pretty decently sort of
no matter how sophisticated you are so I
want to begin by thinking about
something really straightforward which
is Ridge regression I'm gonna it's
basically linear regression with a small
regularizer which we use mostly just for
numerical stability and basis function
expansion I'll be thinking about
quadratic functions rather than linear
functions in this first part but that's
it
so really the kind of regression you'd
learn in the first stats class I speak
about that in the next slide in some
detail but what I mean is we need to
decide how to map from a problem
instance to this finite length vector of
real numbers and you know depending on
how I do that you might say that that's
doing a lot of the work right if you
have terrible features that don't
capture something important then you've
got nothing so you know if I claim that
this is working you know a big part of
my claim must be that I've made a good
guess about what the future should be so
let's think about those features so so
this is the place where I can say the
least
about the generality of what I have to
tell you because every time I go to some
new problem domain I need to think anew
about features it's not quite that bad
because I can go via reductions to sat
and leveraged add features that gives me
something in a general sense but maybe
not maybe that wouldn't be the best
so it's Allah knows how to be not a very
deep learning now but yeah you need to
let me put it unity like most of them to
binary how do I think no no I'd be very
disappointed there really isn't it
really I mean I guess some some concepts
are learn about and some are not right
so if I want to tell you you know I can
predict tomorrow's stock market prices
based on a bunch of data from today look
I did the supervised learning you know I
think you would be suspicious in me I
think you would think you probably don't
have features that could do that you
know many people have tried and you know
they get arbitrage away and it we have
good reasons to think that's probably
not a learn about thing and so you know
if before I came in and started giving
the talk you might have naturally
thought that computational complexity
would provide that kind of barrier that
there might not be cheaply learn about
features that are gonna meaningfully
correlate with runtimes you know it
would seem like you know at least in the
worst case this surely can't work you
know otherwise it's it's kind of an end
run around complexity so so this has to
be making some kind of statement about
what these distributions look like on
average it's as much a statement about
the distributions as it is about the
features and so sure like any time
machine learning is working people have
found features that make sense but it's
it's not a foregone conclusion that
there will always exist such features I
guess what I'm saying is you know this
turns out to be true in these problems
that we've studied you know I can show
you how to do it for sad and we've done
it for some other problems I'll speak
later about TSP and map but you know I I
don't have a set of features that work
out solutely generically but I can tell
you the kinds of features we use which
give you a sense of how you might
approach another problem in this in the
same kind of way so so the most obvious
thing that you would think of if you
take an undergrad algorithms class or
you know in your case hardened undergrad
algorithms class is what's the size of
the problem so you can say for sad what
at the number of clauses with the number
variables what's the clause 2 variables
ratio or what's the length of the binary
encoding of your problem and something
like that and I should say incidentally
I know
a bunch of things and and our approaches
we use all of them we expose just like a
hundred two hundred features to the
learning algorithm and we let the
learning algorithm sort out which
features are useful which ones are not
so when I'm giving you a bunch of
examples you know without fail we used
all of the exact so then you can look at
kind of syntactic properties of the
instance like what's the the ratio of
positive to negative clauses in the
instance something we found quite
fruitful is to look at various
constraint graphs that are generated by
the instance and then look at some
superficial graph properties of these
constraint graphs so and it turns out
for SAP there are three natural
constraint graphs one with variables and
an edge when two variables participate
in the same Clause one with two clauses
where there's an edge if those two
clauses share literal with opposite sign
and one with variables and clauses
bipartite graph and an edge if the
variable participates in the clause each
of these says something different about
the constraint kind of structure of the
sat problem was again I think sorry
there the one on the left yeah so this
is just this is actually the easiest one
to think about so this is just saying
this variable appears in this cause and
so then we can ask you know all kinds of
statistics like you know what's an
average path length between two randomly
chosen nodes or how clustered is the
graph or what what are the degrees of
the variable nodes and what's the
coefficient of variation of the degrees
of the variable nodes and what's the
entropy if something is all these kinds
of things that can boil down sort of a
some kind of vector of values into a
real number we tried a bunch of
different things like this Don Knuth has
a famous way of estimating the the
search space of a search tree which
basically involves just making random
choices so every time you have a branch
you just flip a coin and you just you
run until you get to a refutation you do
this many times and this gives you an
unbiased estimate of the depth of the
tree and this is that then that's that's
a feature that we can use so so unlike
the other features this is kind of a
statistically estimated feature because
we have to do this for some finite
number of samples but it's tractable for
some given finite number
and then we have we have some other
features that like this are sort of
estimated features so we can look at at
heuristic algorithms and use something
about the heuristic to measure a value
and interestingly we can actually
benefit by doing this even when we
reason about other algorithms that are
incredibly different that don't use this
heuristic at all this really just tells
us a property of the instance so for
example if you know about sad you know
about something called unit propagation
which is a way of simplifying a Sat
formula in polynomial time that
sometimes you can do it and sometimes
you can't but if you can it makes the
problem simpler well I guess it depends
on on some approach for ordering
variables but but the point is you can
do that for some way we're in variables
that it gives you a number and that
number is a property of the instance and
I don't have to claim that my algorithm
that I'm studying works in that way at
all in fact I might not know how my
algorithm works because it might be a
black box this is just a way of looking
at an instance and getting a number out
of the instance that I can use as a
feature for my learning so I guess I
haven't formally defined it to you but
you can imagine various ways that I
could define that I can you know
lexicographically order the variables
and then I can always have you know true
be left and false be right and you know
just for some instantiation of it I've
got a feature and the important point is
that the feature doesn't have to be tied
to the algorithm that's one of the the
questions that I'm going to dwell on so
so let me let me get to that
so another class of features that we've
had some success with is looking at
local search algorithms again we might
be trying to understand the performance
of a complete algorithm like KC NFS but
we can nevertheless look at local search
heuristics as a way of generating
properties of an instance so we can say
something like let me look at the
trajectory that a local search algorithm
takes within you know 200 steps or
something and say what's the distance
between its random starting point and
the minimum that it found after it ran
for a certain amount of time or across
several restarts what's the variation in
the height of those minima or let me
look at the first
at OU that it hit and the eventual
plateau that it hit before I cut it off
and what's the ratio of of depths and
the objective function between those two
plateaus or what's the quality of the
best solution that it ever found so I
can ask questions like this and again
these are just properties in the
instance finally I can look at the
linear programming relaxation of Sat
which is a terrible relaxation that
nobody uses for anything because it
isn't very helpful but of course sab has
a linear programming relaxation because
we can write that as a map and then we
can ask things about the variables in
the relaxation we can say things like
what is the norm of these variables you
know how close are they to it so I can
look like the slack vector I can take
every one of these variables what's that
variables distance from 0.5 and then you
know if it's that'll tell me what its
close to being integral or not kind of
on average across the Adsense so I can
do things like that so many of these are
okay this one we rarely use in practice
because it is really pretty slow it's
it's polynomial but but the constants
are pretty bad in this case I mentioned
this one because it plays a role in what
follows although it's actually otherwise
not a very good feature use features
from what I use everything that I can
ever find if somebody at a conference
tells me a new feature then I talked to
my grad students and we try to get it at
it I mean there's no reason to be
selective about it and one of my grad
students is here so his heart is sinking
as he
but it's true that's where the futures
came from and here's an example of how
well we can do so here's again KC NFS on
uniform random 3sat here with a variable
clauses 2 variables ratio I think
varying between 3.5 and 5.5 and here on
the x-axis is the actual run time that
we ran the solver for and here on the
y-axis is how long we predict it so this
is all on held-out test instances that
we didn't use for training so these are
all sat problems that were not seen by
our model when we fit it and we're
looking at how well the model does and
this dotted red line is what perfection
would look like right we we can't
control whether it varies along the x
axis that's just how long the algorithm
took to run but if we've made perfect
predictions we would be right on the
line and you know wait what you see here
looks like sort of a Hot Dog on a Stick
surrounded by a swarm of flies and which
you know at least it does to me I don't
know it looks like to you but
essentially the hotdogs part it's pretty
promising because that's a place where
we're we're doing pretty well and the
Flies are a little bit less promising
because the the variance there is much
higher but at least they're sort of
clustered around the hotdogs you know we
don't have a lot of stuff like way out
here which we you might think that we
would and overall I guess I didn't put
it on this particular apply but in terms
of root mean squared error we're doing
pretty well here and particularly
because scatter plots kind of hide the
fact that we have a lot of density right
on the line yeah yes
so so this is the unset instances and
you can indeed see that that some but
not all of the hotdogs is is the unset
instances which is good it kind of makes
intuitive sense because we would think
there's lower variance there it should
be more predictable based on what we saw
before and indeed you know here we can
do a pretty killer job of predicting
runtime for unset and that's not because
all the unsigned instances had the same
runtime
I mean notice these guys are taking like
a second and these guys are taking like
two minutes and we're able to tell those
apart so yes a great intuition
there are the set of instances that on
the face condition oh look at those next
so this is just varying around the face
transition to begin with and yet here
and these are the satisfiable ones
looking and you know still clustered
around the line but with a lot more
variance so before I go to the face
transition which I will do something
that we might want to know is the
question in fact that you guys asked
before about you know what features are
important to the performance of a model
so at this point in our story I've shown
you a model that does a pretty decent
job of making predictions at this point
you know I've made these sort of grand
promises to you of understanding
something about how the algorithm
performs in practice you might want to
see me actually execute on these grand
promises and if I show you the actual
model that we fit here it would break
your heart because it's so awful to
think about you know we have like a
hundred different features and we're
doing Ridge regression which doesn't
force any values to zero and so your
mate tries to make the values be small
but so what so what I what I have is a
weighted sum of a hundred things that
are all pretty hard to think about and
if you evaluate them all together you
work out the little weighted sum you get
these pretty accurate predictions but
you know what are you gonna do with this
information it doesn't seem like the
starting point for theoretical
understanding and in fact it's even
worse than that because these features
are very correlated with each other
often you know I didn't do anything to
to control for the correlation of one
feature with another feature and so
sometimes the weights you know if some
feature has a big weight that doesn't
really necessarily mean it's important
it might just mean that it gets canceled
out by a bunch of negative weights on
other features that are correlated so
it's really hard to think about you know
anything about what this means and so
what we have to do if we want to try to
understand these things is to winnow
things down to a smaller set of features
that we can think about as humans and
one thing we could do Tim talked about
kind of l1 regularization where you
could sort of hope that the weights get
set to zero by doing and I'll one fit
we've tried that and you know you can
hope but it doesn't always work out so
in fact very often the weights don't we
we get what Tim described as the bad
case where lots of weights are close to
zero and
so that it doesn't make our models very
interpretable so what we do instead is
subset selection so we just exhaustively
try subsets and look at the best small
models and see what they give us and if
that becomes intractable then we do
something greedy where we find the best
model of size K and then we look at all
things we could add of size k plus 1 and
build up models in that way so here I'm
looking at the relatively simple problem
of the varying the closet the variables
ratio so one thing I would want to be
sure of as a sanity check is that our
models discover the importance of this
closet the variables ratio you know if
not then that would be pretty sad if so
I'd want to know in what form they
depend on it and I want to know what
else is going on I seem to be doing
better than than just looking at the
closet the variables ratio so what else
am i benefit in from here so here's what
we find sort of following the statistics
literature which I think it's a bit of a
strange thing but at least when we
generated this we followed them we show
the cost of admission which is the cost
in in loss function so in root mean
squared error of dropping this feature
with the first one normalized 200 and
everything else sort of talking
proportionally about how much the cost
is otherwise I'd be showing you root
mean squared error numbers there would
be sort of mysterious oh this does lets
you think about percentages I'm and so
what we find is you know we hard-coded
in a variable of clause 2 variables
ratio minus 4 point to 6 because we're
working linear models they otherwise
wouldn't be able to find a non-linearity
at four point two six and not to
surprisingly we figure out that this is
important then we figure out the next
most important thing is a nonlinear
relationship in this same quantity
because the relationship isn't linear
and then we have another couple of ways
in which our model depends on the
clauses the variables ratio so so indeed
we do find that for these variable
problems that's really important and but
already in this simple example we're
finding something else that's pretty
important and sort of intriguingly in
our best for variable model which
incidentally is doing pretty close to
the performance of the overall model we
have the same feature showing up twice
in a quadratic feature here and this is
one of these local search features that
I showed you before so this is the
feature that looks at what's the best
objective function value that a local
search algorithm
eventually arrives at so we look at the
SAPS algorithm it is a particular local
search algorithm and we're looking at
the coefficient of variation in these
quantities so we're asking across many
random probes that we run on the local
search solver within a second or
something how much variation is there in
the quality of the solution that it
finds and although we're trying to
characterize KC NFS which is not a local
search algorithm this variability in in
really a very different heuristic its
ability to we're not asking about how
good is the thing that it finds but how
variable is the thing that it finds
turns out to be really informative here
okay so that was all variable ratio
stuff you might think that I was making
things too easy for myself
so let's look here what we should expect
to be a much harder problem the fixed
ratio data we should expect this to be
harder because this is you know before
we knew that the ratio was important
that we found out that it was good for
us you know we planted a click and we
found it
CCI had a bet no I had no idea what I'm
talking about but but but here we kind
of don't know anything right we we don't
we don't have any additional sort of
insights from theory about what might be
important so here's how well we do it's
less well than before but in terms of
root mean squared error it's still
pretty good and now it looks sort of
like a marshmallow
exploding maybe I don't know but but but
this is a place where your eye really
betrays you because these sort of single
points get sort of magnified we have a
lot of points right here in this space
that are that are not nearly so
magnified we don't really have so much
variance on average so this is still
actually doing pretty well there's still
kind of a pattern here and when we dig
in we want to understand what's working
here of course the closet to variables
ratio is no longer shows up as an
important feature because we've held it
constant so that has no purse predictive
value anymore now what we find is that
features to do with local search solvers
are a big part of the story here so we
have this SAP solver some different
properties of the performance of the SAP
solver the thing I identified before is
again when I guess that's looking at the
mean not the coefficient of variation
that plateau but that's that's again
turning out to be important and and here
this ratio between the first plateau and
the eventual plateau is also turning out
to be important so all of these are sort
of properties of local search solvers
this is the search space size estimate
due to Knuth that I mentioned before and
this is a degree statistic of the
variable Clause graph this factor graph
so here's an idea again of the kinds of
things that we can find you know what
properties of the instance are driving
the performance of a solver at the
transition yeah explanation of why the
performance of these local search
heuristics is so and these quantities
about them is so relevant I have a bit
more to say about that which which will
come in the talk so I don't want to
spoil my own punchline but you can
decide at the end whether it's
satisfying to you or not anybody else
okay so now I'm switching over to a
different solver because you know
students graduate and Silver's change
and it's very hard to have all the
graphs be the same so so at this point
we're looking at sat C which is a a
slightly more sophisticated local search
complete search solver here again is the
performance on the variable ratio
problems now you see we're not quite
spearing the hot dog quite as well as
before it's kind of falling off the
stick although I've colored it very
parsimonious ly I guess and but we see
qualitatively we're seeing the same kind
of stuff here and so so now I want to
it's actually this is the the thing
that's gonna sort of respond to what you
had to say so it's something that from
the graphs I've been showing you all
along might not come as a surprise is
that if we condition on the
satisfiability of the instance then
things get a lot easier so it turns out
I can ask what if I only look at the
unsatisfiable data what do I need to
predict there what if I look only at the
satisfiable data what do I need to
predict there and it turns out in each
case a single variable model is
sufficient so I didn't show you a single
variable model before because it didn't
work it was a really lousy prediction
quality but it turns out something based
on local search probing is all you need
for thinking about the satisfiable
problems and this search space size
estimate is all you need to get a good
estimate for the unset
and so my intuition about what was going
on in the previous slide then is that
we're doing some combination of
predicting satisfiability status and
using these ingredients that are
important conditional on satisfiability
status and because it's kind of a mess
you know it's a linear model it's sort
of color you weave together in a
complicated way but it looks like those
are the two ingredients that matter and
they matter in a simple way once we
condition here so then you might think
looks like you know Layton brown if I
don't if I don't misunderstand you here
you're claiming that you can predict
satisfiability status that sounds pretty
crazy but if in fact you could do that
here's something that might be a good
idea you could predict satisfiability
status and then using that prediction
you could reason about these much
simpler models which seem to be a much
cleaner and maybe you could get better
predictions that way now it's not
necessarily the case that this would be
a good idea because the model trained
only on satisfiable vada does really
badly on unsatisfiable data and
vice-versa so this is the sad only model
evaluated on unset data and this this is
how it does on evaluator on everything
and and this is how it does on the
satisfiable data and this is how it does
on the unset data all right so I'm
showing you all these pictures that are
sort of along the line and it makes it
easy for you to think that every picture
in the world would look like that but
this is what a bad picture looks like
right it just absolutely didn't get it
right it's a sort of predicting the same
thing for everything and there's all
kinds of variation and likewise I'm
unset yeah we do reasonably well and on
Saturday absolutely blows up on the sad
stuff so so this kind of approach would
make sense if we don't screw up too
badly here because we're gonna lose
something when we make the wrong choice
in the second step so when we actually
put this all together and this sort of a
mixture of experts story that I could
tell about how we make this work
properly we can go from this model which
has got some bias in it to - this is
predictions on the same data using this
kind of hierarchical approach this is a
much better-looking prediction so this
really does seem to be working better
yes exactly the same features and
because it seems crazy that I could
predict satisfiability let me talk about
that a little bit so so digging in a
little bit deeper we're using a
classifier that predicts the probability
to predict satisfiability and then we
use that probability as an input to the
regression so we take some kind of
weights on the two different predictions
and here's how how often we predicted
each different probability and how
correct we were having predicted it so
you see when we were pretty sure we're
also pretty right and when we're pretty
unsure we're flipping a coin but on the
whole we're right a lot more often than
we're wrong although we're certainly not
right all the time but this maybe seems
a little bit surprising and this is I'm
sorry this graph so like what does
particular probability of set so this is
the output of our classifier so this is
our classifier says I am completely sure
that this is satisfiable or I'm
completely sure that this is
unsatisfiable and then if it's green the
height of this Bart's how often does it
say that and if it's green then that's
that's a case where it was right and if
it's yellow it's a case where it was
wrong it being right what it does it
just gave a probability how can you say
it's right or wrong and so it's it's a
modal thing that it predicted with
scroll and because then eventually
that's what we're gonna use it for and
but I guess what I wanted to know is you
know is it is it learning a confidence
measure that that is accurate is it does
it realize when it doesn't really know
and this is showing that that that does
happen I should mention that I just
switched things here so everything up
until this point I've been looking at
variable ratio but of course this is
more interesting in the fixed ratio case
so this graph is about at the phase
transition and so even at the phase
transition we're predicting
satisfiability status kind of decent
fraction of the time something like 80
percent of the time which seems
surprising because we're not using the
ratio to do that this is fixed ratio
data yeah
but what were the main features yeah
I'll get a direction I mean so far the
answer again is like it's a mess this is
a big complicated thing but so so we dug
into this we had a conversation with
some theorists and they threw scorn on
our idea as they should have so we we
tried to do a much more systematic
investigation of whether this was really
working because it did seem surprising
to us so we considered phase transition
instances varying from a hundred
variables which is super easy we can
solve it in milliseconds anything
smaller than that we start worrying that
the processor cache has a dramatic
effect on the CPU time measurement to
600 variables which is about the biggest
thing that you can solve before your
solver never finishes and what we wanted
to know is whether there was an effect
in the quality of prediction accuracy as
we varied from these super-easy
instances to these really hard as misses
and if not whether we could identify a
more easily comprehensible model and to
try to make this all as sort of robust
as possible we tied our hands Spiner
backs in three ways we trained only on
one hundred variable problems which is
the super trivial to solve ones and we
had to use that model on the big
problems that had never got to train on
we built models consisting only of
decision trees within most two nodes so
that we would actually be able to look
at the model and understand what it was
doing and we emitted all of the probing
features because they're really
effective on the small instances they
can sometimes solve the small instances
and as helpful as they were they were
kind of distracting for us and because
there's a less clean theoretical story
that can be told about what they're
doing and furthermore they might skew
our training on the very simple problems
so we looked only at these kind of graph
structure kind of instances well you
know the problem features that's right
maybe they needs that word before that's
they sort of statistically estimated
features so the search space size
estimate and running the local search
solvers for a certain amount of time so
most of what has turned out to be useful
in the talk so far has been probing
features so I'm not allowing myself to
use any of those it turns out if I don't
use them other things come and take
their place but that is not quite as
good and so here is
an actual model that does pretty well
and here's its classification accuracy
across problem sizes now the bottom of
this I'm not cheating here the bottom of
this is 50% so this would be random
guessing so anything above is really
finding something now you know we did
some statistical tests to try to
determine whether there seemed to be a
trend that this was falling and we see
we have no statistical evidence for a
trend that it's following you can kind
of eyeball it if anything the test told
us that it might be slowly rising which
when you look at it does seem a little
bit like that but mostly it seems just
not really to be changing and here's the
model I can tell you what the model does
because it's this decision tree with
only two variables and and this model
was trained only on these hundred
variable problems so so here I just
defining the features in more detail but
something to do with the lp slack of
that terrible linear programming
relaxation is by far our most useful
feature in fact almost all of the
accuracy of the model comes in the root
node there so so let me tell you exactly
what we do
so we look at SATs linear programming
relaxation and then four we compute this
LP slack vector which is the minimum of
1 minus each solution variable and the
solution variable so we're looking at
you know how close it is to an extremal
value and then we we take the
coefficient of variation of this vector
and so so that's our one feature and
then here we're asking and then there's
a little bit of a trick that if I want
to be fully formal I have to tell you
about which is that all of these values
just kind of change as instance sizes
grow so we normalized everything so that
features would have mean 0 and standard
deviation 1 that normalization the
normalization required is different at
different problem sizes and so when we
evaluate our model on a problem size
that it wasn't trained on we have to
estimate the normalization which we can
do without cheating because we're
looking at uniform random 3sat so we
just generate a whole lot of uniform
random 3sat instances of the appropriate
size use it just to estimate the
normalization factors for the features
we compute the features on these things
many times figure out how to normalize
them and then use those normal
Asian factors on the one test instance
so that that's not cheating but it's a
little bit complicated and then so
that's why these numbers are kind of
close to zero because these are mean
zero values so what we're saying is if
the lp slack coefficient of variation is
a little bit bigger than its mean one
might wonder if it's almost as good just
to say zero here then it's probably
satisfiable so the model says yeah in
that case it's satisfiable otherwise
let's look at the ratio of positive to
negative variables which is defined like
this I won't walk through all the
details but it's just looking at the
syntactic ratio of positive and negative
occurrences of a variable averaged
across variables and if if that is that
ratio is substantially bigger than the
average then I'll say again that it's
satisfiable and otherwise I'll say that
it's unsatisfiable so that's our whole
model this this is able at the phase
transition to predict satisfiability
with something like 75% accuracy so why
does that happen I have no idea maybe
some of some of you will someday tell me
but this is the kind of thing that we
can use these kinds of methods to find
out and I think something like this is
at least a starting point for for
thinking theoretically yeah that's right
that's right so here we're only looking
at the variation we're not looking we
have other features that talk about the
actual values like the mean at the LP
slack which weren't selected by our
model we certainly allowed for that to
matter but what it but it chose to care
about is this variation you told me yeah
hello I don't have the number but it's
almost as good because actually this
leaf is pretty close to fifty percent
accuracy which means that just calling
this whole thing unsaid is almost the
same because you were almost random
guessing and so just collapsing the
whole thing is almost as good so if you
were to think about a theoretically I
think you'd be fine just to think about
only the lp slack feature yeah I think
that's doing most of the work it's
certainly much better than random
guessing and of course I know nothing
about the asymptotics here I just know
that you know scaling up as big as we
can scale we don't see anything
happening maybe it's tapering off very
slowly you know again how can I say okay
how are we doing
I think we're exactly at the point where
we should stop so here's our transition
let's come back in half an hour